[Music]
the year of the Batman reveals continues
the first trailer for the second season
of the DC Universe series Titans has
been released and that gives fans a
first look at Ian's Glens Bruce Wayne
and as an added bonus Esai Morales is
Deathstroke canonically the Titans most
persistent nemesis Titans is the
inaugural original series effort for DC
Universe and its first season racked up
accolades for its dark year humorous
take on the Teen Titans
DC's classic superhero team led by Dick
Grayson better known as Robin join the
first season at the rest of the team
included Rachel Roth or Raven the alien
corriander aka Starfire and gar Logan
otherwise known as Beast Boy the group
also crossed paths with Donna Troy also
known as Wonder Girl Hank Hall aka Hawk
and dawn Granger aka dove all of whom
can be spotted briefly in the trailer
for season two fans had an inkling that
Bruce Wayne would be a part of this new
season at the conclusion of season 1
Robert in Jordan episode lung Colusa
nation in which he five years in the
future was forced to track down and kill
an out-of-control Batman the elaborate
elucidation was an effort on the part of
the demon Trigon Rachel's father to take
control of Grayson's mortal form it's a
goal he seems to accomplish at the
season's end but we'll have to wait and
see how that plays out fans have been
psyched to catch a glimpse of Glennis
Wayne and we got one however brief well
we can report that he looks to pass well
they were not so sure that he exactly
sounds like The Dark Knight he made the
news with your old night news prayers
no one's due Glen is Scottish and we're
sure that in his mind he's doing a
flawless American accent but to American
ears it sounds a bit dodgy
aside from Wayne the spice also
introduces viewers to Drew van ackers
Aqualad and Chelsea tease Aang's ravager
and that his conclusion Deathstroke
standing bathed in shadow at the end of
a dark foreboding hallway obviously we
don't get a good look at the villains
costume but he sure cuts a badass
menacing figure and we're sure that's
not the only thing you'll be cutting he
didn't bring along those swords for
nothing also in a moment fans have been
waiting for since it was teased in the
post credits tinker of the season one
finale we get a look at Joshua opens
Superboy and Krypto the Superdog we
don't get to see the pooch in action but
we're thinking of the show's producers
didn't want to tip their hand too soon
will he be wearing a cape when he
bounced into action not
would be the icing on the cake if like
us you're a big fan of the Dark Knight's
this year has been and will continue to
be a very good one in terms of giving us
more live action Batman then you can
shake up Batarang Gertz first the series
finale of gotham finally gave us a shows
version of the caped crusader something
that all been anticipating for the
entirety of the show's run September
will see the premiere of Titans second
season and in December the CW's arrow
verse will stage another of its huge
crossover events one with a name that
every single DC fan will recognize
crisis on Infinite Earths cast in the
role of Bruce Wayne for the multiverse
mashup Kevin Conroy who has provided the
voice of the character and animated
series features and video games for over
2 decades many bat fans in fact believe
his interpretation of Bruce Wayne to be
the definitive one and you'll get no
argument from us DC Universe made
serious waves of this cancellation of
Swamp Thing after only one episode of
his truncated first season of Ed but any
rumblings that the service may be in
danger of folding have seemingly been
put to rest with Doom Patrol recently
renewed for a second season and
amazingly not-safe-for-work trailer for
the animated Harley Quinn series and now
our first look at what appears to be a
smashing new season for Titans we'll
keep our ears to the ground for any news
concerning the stream a slate of
original series and keep you up to speed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite superhero shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]